but when you were in prison what crew
did you roll with like what was your car
there was really no cruise at that time
you had the brothers you had the biggest
problem I had was navigating around the
Bloods and the crypts because I worked
in the kitchen
now is it easier to navigate that when
you're when you have a kitchen job in
1987 I didn't even know the blood in the
[__] work uh so I guess we didn't have
anything back east no the Bloods and
Crips are just starting in like the late
70s I got into the way you go the first
day you get the council's like have you
ever had hepatitis B
yeah so they put me in the kitchen the
dude was big Mr Yarbrough big brother
out of the Navy Korean Navy guy and he's
like Mr Diaz you look like Italian so
I'm gonna make you a baker have you ever
baked before and I'm like no I don't
even cook so I went in there next
morning at four in the morning and he's
like you put this much on the thing and
then they expand I'm like why are you
being so cheap brother
pretty much the living in cells give
them a big Cinnamon Muffin I mean I
didn't know he's like he can't make them
big I didn't know why so I made them big
and they became manhole covers Robin
almost blew up there was a fire so he
fired me he made me the stock clerk
which is the best job there I don't even
know what stock clerk it's a stock clerk
you ordered the food for the kitchen uh
and you have your own facility to hide
[__] for the other invicts because it's
so far away they don't bring the dogs to
sniff that [__] an adult driver's
license so you see those guys that pick
papers up on the side of the road I
would bring them lunch in the cart so I
could always go you're gonna be here
tomorrow yeah I could always go Andrew
Schultz have your girlfriend drop off an
ounce of coke I garbage stop number 54.
you're gonna pick it up and put it in
the garbage I'm gonna come by to give
you lunch you're gonna give it to me
they're not going to search me to go
back into the facility you have no idea
how why I'm getting Coke into the today
they had everything I wasn't throwing
Coke at all no no but getting it in
there yeah they had Coke in there heroin
the only thing I was doing there was
acid because they couldn't desperate
acid in prison yeah you get nice blotter
acid in prison I get [__] up every
Sunday night me and some other guys we'd
sit outside and talk [__] and crack
jokes they couldn't figure out and
they'd automatically give you a piss
test the next day clean because you're
out and you're clean whoa did you like
prison in in the social aspect I loved
it yeah cause you're a king right yeah
everybody loves you you've got these
Amazing Stories I'm in the kitchen and
that's the hardest part I had was the
Crips and the Bloods okay because in the
kitchen they kind of got along
[Music]
outside the kitchen they had to maintain
their status and I really dug that but
it was I was friends with Crips my best
friend was a [__] in there yeah I love
this mother yeah this guy had seven
girlfriends each of them with a badass
six-figure car this guy was in charge of
bringing cocaine from California to
Colorado for the Crips
this is at this time this is what he did
was to chick that went to the Olympics
Joyner in the 80s her brother was in
there too he was a [__] or something
because he was bringing him in Coke yeah
that's when the Crips of bringing him
from La yeah California all those little
things so that was the hardest
adjustment I had you had your bikers
like five little raggedy bikers you had
you had your white supremacist a couple
of them it would only add 104 people
okay so everybody kind of knows
everybody so you didn't have that you
had one Italian and he was the cook of
course and I partnered up with him to
start a book making operation because he
couldn't sell lottery tickets to the
blacks to Spanish uh but I could ah I
knew how to talk to the brothers and I
know how to talk to the Mexicans so he
made me his partner and every night he
would make nachos he'd get like an iron
and put it melted to cheese and [__]
get chips and [__] [__] different
world so you having it weirdly the time
of your life yes the first listen like I
got sentenced August 15th yeah the
system was a year behind
what that meant what does that mean the
system was a year behind that time when
Matt was you're not getting processed to
go to your prison until [__] December
or January oh you're in jail still so
you're gonna sit in uh this is why I got
off okay there's a lot of people don't
know
so I got sentenced to second degree
burglary it cost me I had to pay a lot
of money because I had to hired
investigator to prove
there was no violence in my past because
they wanted to charge me with a violent
offensive so that means if I got nine
years for kidnapping I would do all nine
years oh yeah and I was not gonna do
that yeah so we had to hired
investigated and go back to Jersey and
[__] any violence as a kid like yeah
we have to a fist fight with a pizza guy
[__] like that but nothing extreme that
showed this so my attorney that was his
most important thing was to get the
violent crime changed to a non-violent
crime because that makes complete big
difference and he did it that might be
the greatest miracle in the history
you need to he's in Colorado Springs and
now he's got a kid that once again to
the entertainment business so he's like
what do we need to do
hey back's a [__]
so when I got sentenced I got sentenced
to 48 months right
but I spent the month in County time
served so that's too much oh you get
double time served for County Cally's
two days
at that time it was two for one so I did
a month
so that meant I did two months so now
it's 22 months
I got in there right
until you hit prison
your final destination it's two for one
wow so the longer you stay in the county
the shorter amount of time you're gonna
have to spend in prison I guess this is
the idea is Expediting your time at
County because counties are paying the
[__] up pain in the ass but not bad
because again I got sentenced on a
Monday and by Wednesday morning I was
taken out they told me they were going
to send me to like Oklahoma they sent me
to [__]
Summit County Jail guys we wore our own
clothes and we played handball outside
and at nine o'clock the jail the [__]
guards would go
it's a safe way for you and buy you
chips sodas and we'd watch movies all
night on TV it was low-key and
everybody's too key my buddy in there
was a guy from the Bronx Italian dude
[__] as soon as I get that a guy
[__] hugged me I'll do anything for
you just talk to me brother just talk to
me I haven't been around people from the
East Coast this guy loved me so I became
friends with him and we were [__] I
didn't drink or anything in that but we
would always like [__] gamble a lot
of gambling in that okay you know I was
in Summit County for maybe two weeks
that's a month boom so you're shaving
time off shave them shaving time off so
now I had three months already awesome
one morning and they go you're going to
[__] Department of Corrections
so first you go to DLC and say ah you go
to diagnostic
that's where you're there for two weeks
they find out what's wrong with you they
check everything your ass yeah your mind
they ask you creepy questions they do a
battery a test and then from what how
you do on that
is where you're decided where your
destination is
so you're trying to do better on that
yes because if you look sane you look
competent you look smart you're going to
get the country club and if you look
like an absolute Savage [__] up but
still I didn't have the numbers
I knew that my numbers were low because
before you get sentenced you have to
take a thing like a little test like a
10 question test not in the heart yeah
did you have a job before you got
arrested did you have a license before
you got arrested were you working at the
time of your arrest and all these
positive things count you a favor so
after I got sentenced before I went to
after I went through diagnostic now
they're going to send you to your
destination
I had two destinations I could either go
to rifle Colorado and that's where I
wanted to go because in the winter they
let you be a ski instructor yeah yeah
but a dude on the hill yeah checking
people's badges unbelievable and in the
summer you could be a lifeguard at the
pool the job is the pool
so I'm like what do you find and they
let you go to the movies on Saturday
night unbelievable golden was where I
went Camp George West I wanted to go to
Golden because it was closer to my house
but they didn't have all the [__] rifle
had yeah you don't ski and go hang by
the pool but the only thing they had
they let you out for 20 minutes today to
go to the store no there was a bodega
right around the corner yeah 20 minutes
of Freedom 20 minutes just to run to the
store and run back
so I started come on Doug you got
everybody else couldn't figure it out I
started ordering Chinese food so this to
the bodega to the bodega there was a
Chinese restaurant next to it so I would
call the order in because all the other
idiots would actually go to Bodega and I
go did you get Chinese food and they go
no we don't have time I'm like you got
to call the order in so when you get
there so I would call the order and pick
up Chinese food pick up a couple
Haagen-Dazs some ice creams and [__] so
you were a [__] superhero you're
coming back with ice cream
Chinese food oh my God